[Music]  somebody there  [Music]  somebody  who said that  don't play the innocent with me  you've known all along  where are you  follow the cold shiver running down your  spine  i'm right here  i don't understand  did you think it was coincidence  so many good things all happening for  you all for you  norman  what do you want  to say what you want  to do what you can't  to remove  those in your way  the board members  you killed them we killed them  we  remember  your little accident in the laboratory  the performance enhancers bingo  me your greatest creation  bringing you what you've always wanted  power beyond your wildest dreams and  it's only the beginning  there's only one  who can stop us  or  imagine if he joined us  you